mr. chase can you please tell us the  first thing you remember from the  simulation nobody can remember anything  at all about how and what I mean our  plane went down I don't know I just want  to figure this thing out we haven't seen  half the ship this Islands gonna throw  at us you're gonna die out here we have  to be ready or we try to get out of here  it's all about to get a whole lot more  intense now if you do something wrong  the island it pays you back  something's off of her  checker something too  I think I'll finally begin to understand  the rules of this place  if you die in there  you're dead out here to east choice  determines the next challenge I think  they've got a chance in there not if I  got anything to say about it you know I  just remembered my lunches  you